yes there's a new warcraft trailer out
there and ultimately it is we're talking
about the first sponsorship because
sponsors love that and Stephanie to get
paid this video is brought to you by
audible where they have over a hundred
and eighty thousand audio book title for
you to choose from I have a link in the
description sign up through that and get
yourself a free 30-day trial - audible
we'll talk more about that later but for
right now let's talk about the new
warcraft trailer okay so like I just
said this trailer is worth talking about
it ultimately is we're talking about
because it's balls I don't like it I
said on Twitter that it was balls and
people are like what get balls or bad
balls balls could be good or bad which
balls yeah bad balls this is balls I
don't like and maybe I'm being unfair to
this Warcraft earlier maybe I'm just
taking what they initially envisioned
for the Warcraft movie back when they
first wanted to do it and I'm just still
holding to that now the initial thing I
heard was that they wanted to make a
Warcraft movie that is somewhere between
Lord of the Rings and Braveheart and in
a world where trailers are supposed to
show you the tone of what the movies
supposed to be that's not here any
trailer with that done and yeah neither
Lord of the Rings nor Braveheart had
that music at all ever in it now to be
clear I'm not saying the movies gonna
suck Duncan Jones's the director he is
the reason I'm like this could be the
movies to be the video game movie that
we've all been hoping for for decades
dudes a great director he's fantastic
the lore in the Warcraft world is very
lush fleshed out lore and so in no point
even if the trailers suck at no point am
I gonna just write this movie off and be
like oh I'm just saying this trailers
not good and they should probably come
out with another trailer kind of like
they did with ghostbusters like alright
we'll fix what you didn't like and now
we have a new Ghostbusters trailer yeah
I do that marketing department gets some
of that epic choir music going there are
companies that just make epic as trailer
music for trailers like Warcraft there's
really this trailer doesn't show us
anything that we didn't already know
it's like you have orcs you have humans
are war with each other but they have to
work together to take out a greater evil
and there's a hot or chick all the other
orcs are really stocky and beefy and
they walk around they're all CGI no look
hey let's make super hottie it's still
super hottie but green hey I get it
don't don't
shit's in my head I'll tell you that you
really hit the point home here do you
think Braveheart would have had the
trailer music like that you think
never take afraid this war will destroy
us all
how about Lord of the Rings
if a cross between or somewhere in
between Braveheart and Lord of the Rings
is what you're aiming for this trailer
doesn't illustrate that could be a
marketing department thing maybe Duncan
Jones is like I hate that [ __ ] - babe
marketing is marketing what can you do I
don't have any control over that or
worst case scenario it's exactly what
the movies going to be like and we're
all just wasting our time hoping for
this movie to come out so who knows the
thing is with trailers you never know
I've seen trailers for movies that
looked great it turned out to be [ __ ]
trailers that looked like [ __ ] where the
movie turned out to be great where does
that look great where the movie turned
out to be great trailers that look [ __ ]
really movie turned out to be [ __ ] I've
seen it all for this trailer I just
don't like this trailer really if you're
gonna ask is it just the music that you
hate yeah it's just the music that I
hate in fact is there someone out there
with editing skills who can edit this
trailer to better music I just I would
love to see that and I'm feeling it's
already out there but still I'd love to
see it so we'll see what happens guys I
really want to know what you guys think
of it so the new Warcraft trailer have
you seen it what did you think about it
whatever you think comment below let me
know and remember this video was brought
to you by audible or they have over a
hundred and eighty thousand audiobooks
yeah that's pitch talk right there you
know you love it but the one I listened
to I really did this because I wouldn't
pitch it if I didn't actually enjoy it I
was reading or listening to you rather
of The Selfish Gene by Richard Dawkins
and I was like I would like to listen to
that like it's a lecture in a lecture
hall rather than just sitting down and
reading it so I had it hooked through my
echo and I just listened to it I would
listen to it when I was at home and I'd
listen to it when I was driving and
before you know it you're finished and
you have all the information in your
head it's really a good book - again I
have a link in the description you sign
up through that you get yourself a free
30-day trial - audible browsers are
crazy over 180,000 title library and
just get imbued with audiobook knowledge
how it works right America and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more